なんだろうなぁ...
なんか、これと言って「これが参考です！」
みたいなの ないんですけど...
なんか、ホラー映画とかで
ｯﾊﾟ！...ﾋﾟｮﾝ...ﾊﾟｯ!!!!!!!
みたいな こうなんか
電気が消えて
点いた瞬間 怖いヤツがいるみたいな...
映画観たこと。よくありませんか？
あれちょっとやってやりてぇなと思いまして...
たなっち！！！！
最近、ほぼ２４時間 一緒にいるたなっち！
新居に最近移ったみたいです！
おめでとうございます！！！！
８８８８８８８８
というわけで、ちょっと彼の新居で
ドッキリしてみたいと思います！！
要するに、彼は最近こっちに来たばっかりだから
このなんか...土地のね！
なんかこう...生業とかなにも知らない訳ですよ
なんで、彼にちょっと
彼の住んでる新居に近くに
ちょっと幽霊みたいなのが、
いるかもしれないよぉ...
ってことをちょっと唆しといて
たなっち「ふえぇ...怖いっすねwww」
みたいなこと言うと思うんですけど...
そのちょっと
恐怖心を煽った状態で
...と僕が急にブレーカーを落とします！
ブレーカー、バシンッ！て落として
でブレーカー点いたら！
ホント映画にみたいなやつです
こうやって ね？いるじゃん？...
で？
ピョン！
消えます。真っ暗になりました。
点いた瞬間！
ﾊｯ!ﾊｯ!...
ﾊｯ!!
Prrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr!!!!!!
みたいなやつをやりたいわけですよ...
wwww
ﾓﾘｱｶﾞｯﾃｷﾀｱｱ…↑↑
とりあえず、 僕がたなっちの家に乗り込んで
怖い話をして
でそのあと、たなっちを何とかして
外に出して
その間に、セッティングしたいと思います。
とりあえず、たなっちの新居に行ってみましょう
では...
ｻｻｯ...
さっき応答したのはお父さんとかがなんか...
あ！！
いるのかな？
とも、友達です...
あぁ、友達がいるんだwww
多分、友達のベットです。それ
あぁそぉなんだw
そwwww
ひっろ！？きれいやなぁ...
wwwww
ベットでぇすwwww
そういう訳じゃないです
あ、す...
たまたま...
あ、ホントに ぬ...
へ、え？
たまたま鉢合わせでwww
たまたま鉢合わせ！？
そう...
失礼しまぁす！
こうか、こうが良いんですけど...
はい...
どちらで...
どうが良いんですかねぇ...
いいな！きれいだな！いいな！いいな！
ねぇぇ...
にゃ！
あ！ホントだ！Wi-Fiかこれ！
パスワードは「５８２９６２８６」です。
おいおいおいおい！！
こうか...
ここら辺...なんか...
夜、怖いらしいっすよ
なにが？
おばけ？？
おばけ
いや、俺はおばけ大丈夫な人なんで...
おばけ、怖くない？
いや、おばけは怖いっすよ
おん...
こわいけど...
出ちゃったら...
あぁ、落ち着いちゃう系？
あぁ///出ちゃった/////
あぁぁ/////////////
ってなる
wwwwwwwwwww
冷静だなぁ...
あの、なんかそういう噂がねぇ
ここら辺の地域にあるらしくて...
はい
まぁ 夜、怖い思いするかもしれないっすねw
えぇ...さ、さすがにね...？
？
（お腹痛いのかなぁ...）
行ってきなさい（トイレに）
喉、乾いちゃった！
あ、喉乾いたの！？
喉、乾いちゃった
何...
お茶でいいですか？
ううん...
何？
頭悪ぃや ホントにwwww
たなっち買ってきてぇ！！
ホントにw
いってらっしゃいい！！
いってきやぁっす...
というわけで、
ターゲットが今、外に出ているので
仕掛けます...
タオルとか予備のパーツがこうやって入ってます
はい
で、その他もこのまま入れときますんで
はい、とっといてやって下さい
ありがとうございました！
あ、はいはい
お疲れ様です！
はい
すげぇ！ベットじゃないっすか！
いや、マジ ベットだよ！
デカ、ベットw
まって...
ちょっと、そのままベットで遊んで
なんじゃそれぇwwwwww
バチン！！
うわ！？...
たなっち？？
はい...
停電だ...
たなっち、停電だ！
いやぁ...曰く付きの物件家！
いやwガチwガチwガチw
たなっち、ブレーカーをちょっと...
ブレーカーとかあんま良く分かんないんすよね、俺ぇ...
ブレーカー詳しくないって
うん...
暗っ！
なになになに...
多分、開けてなんとかするしかない。この扉...
うわ！怖っ！
なになになに...
待って、怖い怖い怖い...
なに？
ね、怖い...
これを開けて
なに、開けたらなんか...
なんか出てくんの？
開けて...
見えな！？
え、真っ暗でなにも見えないっすもん
え、全部落ちてない？
落ちてない。多分
どれ？
だから、その...
右上のそれを
クイッって上げて
これ？
それそれそれ
めっちゃ上げたら多分なると思う
えぇ、怖い怖い怖い！
バチン！
うぉおお！？！？
うぉおお！？！？びっくりした！
マジびっくりしたこれは！
やりやがった！
これはびっくりするって！
うわ、人はびっくりする！
たなっち、びっくりした？w
いや、びっくりしたぁ...ホント！
２人いるとは思わなかったっしょ？
うん...
ホンｔ...なにやってんすか！ホントに！ww
ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑
ﾍﾟｰ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟｰ↑ﾍﾟｰ↓
ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟｰ↓
ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟｰ↑ﾍﾟｰ↑
ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟｰ↓ｯﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟｯ↑
ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟｰ↓ﾍﾟｰ↑ﾍﾟｰｰｰｰ↓(ﾍﾞｰｰｰｰ↓ﾍﾞｰｰｰｰ↑)
ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑(ﾍﾞｯ↓ﾍﾞｯ↑ﾍﾞｯ↓ﾍﾞｯ↑)
ﾍﾟ・ﾍﾟ・ﾍﾟ・ﾍﾟﾝ☆
時間なくて、なりきれなかったおばけ！
wwwwwwwwwwwwwww
間に合わなかったんすよね
見て、ほら
wwww
wwwwwwwwwwwwwww
ハードギアww（？）